ils auront tremblé jusqu'à la dernière
seconde de ce 7e tour de coupe de france
opposéà le est nantais relais châteaux
pourtant dominateurs en début de
rencontre concède le premier but un
penalty à la 31e minute qu'il n'aura pas
éteint les espoirs cateau view on a pris
un but contre le cours du jeu mais on a
su revenir très vite en revenant très
vite avant la mi temps ça nous a un peu
de force et ça je suis fier ils ont bien
réagi et on égalise on met le 2 on
pourrait même mettre le 3 l'équipe
parvient à inverser la tendance pour
rentrer aux vestiaires à la mi temps en
92 busan dans la volonté dans la dans
notre façon de entreprendre ne pas subir
la rencontre on a été bien on a pris les
choses en main dès le début on a essayé
de jouer les fidèles à nous mêmes poussé
par le public chatou wallemme inscrire
un troisième but cinq minutes après la
reprise avant de subir les pressions
adverses en deuxième mi-temps on met le
troisième et après on souffre comme un
vrai match de coupe quoi rouler qui
prend tous les risques et nous on est là
on ne sait pas trop si on doit défendre
ou attaquer et au final ça tiens et si
tu sais le charme de la coupe malgré la
réduction du score encaissé à la 67e
minute chatou tient bon et s'imposent
finalement 3 buts à 2 il accède donc au
8e tour le 27 novembre prochain aller le
plus loin possible là je pense qu'au jeu
chartres qui a gagné donc objectif
faire un match correct costaud et s'est
passé le tour en cas d'exploit face aux
c# pensionnaire de nationale 2 château
pourrait même se frotter à l'élite du
football français les clubs de ligue 1
entreront en lice au 9e tour
[Musique]